have you ever wondered how large
language models can understand and
respond to questions like human beings
well one of the key techniques we use is
called prompting prompting involves
providing the LM with Specific
Instructions or cues to guide the
reasoning and response recently
researchers have developed a new and
advanced prompting technique called
react it aims combine the best of two
roles the reasoning ability ofs was the
ability to interact with external World
react can validate the model reasoning
and update its knowledge by allowing the
LM to interact with external source of
information such as website or database
in the previous shorts I talked about R
so what are the difference between them
react emphasize the ability to interact
with external world to take action and
gather information where RG emphasize
the ability to access them